ou couvrir un enfant de honte pour son manque d'efforts à l'école.
100% d'entre nous seront les destinataires
de comportements malsains dans des relations
et 100% d'entre nous feront des choses malsaines.
C'est cela, être humain.
Dans sa forme la pire, le mal causé aux êtres aimés
est de la maltraitance et de la violence
et une relation violente
est une chose qu'une femme sur trois et un homme sur quatre
connaîtront au cours de leur vie.
Si vous êtes comme beaucoup, quand vous entendez ces chiffres,
vous vous dites : « Oh non, cela ne m'arrivera jamais. »
Il est instinctif de s'éloigner des mots « maltraitance » et « violence »,
de croire que cela arrive à quelqu'un d'autre, ailleurs.
Mais en vérité, les relations malsaines et la maltraitance nous entourent.
Nous les appelons autrement et ignorons le lien qu'il y a.
La maltraitance s'infiltre sournoisement, déguisé en amour malsain.
Je travaille pour l'organisation One Love,
créée par une famille dont la fille, Yeardley, a été tuée par son ex petit-ami.
C'est une tragédie que personne n'a vu venir,
mais ils ont réalisé que les signes avant-coureurs étaient là
mais personne n'a compris ce qu'il voyait.
Dites folles, dramatiques ou alcoolisées,
ses actions n'étaient pas prises pour ce qu'elles étaient vraiment :
des signes clairs de danger.
Sa famille a réalisé que si quelqu'un avait été informé sur ces signes,
sa mort aurait pu être évitée.
Notre mission est de nous assurer
que les autres aient les informations que Yeardley et ses amis n'avaient pas.
Nous avons trois grands objectifs :
fournir à tout le monde le langage pour parler d'un sujet
dont il est embarrassant et désagréable de parler ;
habiliter toute une première ligne, c'est-à-dire les amis, à aider ;
au passage, améliorer notre capacité à tous à aimer mieux.
Pour ce faire, il est toujours important de commencer en éclaircissant
les signes malsains que nous ratons souvent
et notre travail se concentre sur la création de contenus
pour engager une conversation avec les jeunes.
Comme on pourrait s'y attendre, notre contenu est sérieux
étant donné le sujet traité,
mais aujourd'hui je vais utiliser l'un de nos contenus les plus légers
suscitant la réflexion,
« Les couplets »,
pour éclaircir cinq indicateurs d'un amour malsain.
Le premier est l'intensité.
(Vidéo) Bleu : Je ne t'ai pas vu depuis quelques jours. Tu m'as manqué.
Orange : Toi aussi. (#cestcalamour)
Bleu : Je ne t'ai pas vue depuis cinq minutes.
C'est une éternité.
Qu'as-tu fait sans moi durant cinq minutes entières ?
Orange : Cela fait trois minutes. (#cenestpascalamour)
Katie Hood : Vous reconnaissez cela ?
Moi oui.
Les relations abusives ne commencent pas ainsi.
Au début, elles sont excitantes et exaltantes.
Il y a une intensité dans l'affection et l'émotion, une frénésie.
C'est une sensation très plaisante.
Vous vous sentez si chanceux, comme si vous aviez remporté le jackpot.
Mais dans un amour malsain, ces sentiments changent avec le temps,
passant d'excitants à accablants, voire un peu étouffants.
C'est un sentiment viscéral.
Peut-être que votre nouveau petit ami ou petite amie
dit « je t'aime » avant que vous ne soyez prêt
ou apparaît partout, envoie des messages et appelle beaucoup.
Peut-être est-il impatient quand vous mettez du temps à répondre,
même s'il sait que vous aviez d'autres choses prévues ce jour-là.
Il est important de se rappeler
que ce qui importe n'est pas le début de la relation,
mais comment elle évolue.
Il est important, au début d'une nouvelle relation,
de prêter attention à ce que vous ressentez.
Êtes-vous à l'aise avec la progression de l'intimité ?
Avez-vous l'impression d'avoir la place de respirer ?
Il est aussi très important de vous entraîner à utiliser votre voix
pour parler de vos besoins.
Vos demandes sont-elles respectées ?
Un deuxième indicateur est l'isolement.
(Vidéo) Orange 2 : Tu veux sortir ?
Orange 1 : Mon copain et moi avons des lundis amusants.
Orange 2 : Tu veux sortir ?
Orange 1 : Mon copain et moi avons des lundis festifs.
Orange 2 : Demain ? Orange 1 : Mardi, on roupille.
Orange 2 : Mercredi ? Orange 1 : Jour sans amis.
KH : L'isolement est l'un des signes les plus souvent négligés
et incompris de l'amour malsain.
Pourquoi ?
Car toute nouvelle relation démarre avec ce désir intense
de passer du temps ensemble,
il est facile de ne pas voir quand quelque chose change.
L'isolement s'installe quand votre nouveau copain ou copine
commence à vous éloigner de vos amis et de votre famille,
votre système de soutien,
et à vous attacher plus fermement à lui.
Il pourrait dire :
« Pourquoi traînes-tu avec eux ? Ce sont des ratés. »
de vos meilleurs amis
ou « Ils veulent que l'on rompe. Ils sont contre nous. »
de votre famille.
L'isolement sème le doute
sur toutes les personnes de votre vie d'avant la relation.
Un amour sain comprend de l'indépendance,
deux personnes aimant passer du temps ensemble
mais qui restent en contact avec les gens et les activités auxquels ils tenaient.
Si au début vous pourriez passer chaque minute ensemble,
avec le temps, la clé est de maintenir de l'indépendance.
Vous y parvenez en faisant des projets avec des amis et en vous y tenant
et en encourageant votre partenaire à en faire de même.
Un troisième indicateur d'un amour malsain est une jalousie extrême.
(Vidéo) Bleu 2 : Pourquoi es-tu si heureux ?
Bleu 1 : Elle vient juste de s'abonner à mon Instagram !
Bleu 2 : Pourquoi es-tu si nerveux ?
Bleu 1 : Elle vient juste de s'abonner à tous mes comptes, partout.
(#cenestpascalamour)
KS : Alors que la période de lune de miel s'estompe,
une jalousie extrême peut s'insinuer.
Votre partenaire pourrait devenir plus accaparant,
demandant constamment à savoir où vous êtes et avec qui
ou il pourrait commencer à vous suivre partout, en ligne et hors ligne.
Une jalousie extrême entraîne aussi de la possessivité et de la suspicion,
des accusations fréquentes de flirter avec d'autres ou de le tromper
et un refus de vous écouter quand vous lui dites
qu'il n'y a aucune raison de s'inquiéter et que vous n'aimez que lui.
La jalousie fait partie de toute relation humaine,
mais la jalousie extrême est différente.
Elle a un côté menaçant, désespéré et virulent.
L'amour ne devrait pas être ainsi.
Un quatrième indicateur est du dénigrement.
(Vidéo) Bleu : Tu veux sortir ? Orange : Je dois étudier.
Bleu : Tu auras une bonne note, tu es géniale. (#cestcalamour)
Bleu : Tu veux sortir ? Orange : Je dois étudier.
Bleu : Tu auras un zéro,
tu es ... stupide. (#cenestpascalamour)
KH : Ouais, hum.
Dans un amour malsain, les mots sont des armes.
Les conversations qui étaient amusantes et légères
deviennent épouvantables et gênantes.
Peut-être que votre partenaire se moque de vous d'une façon blessante
ou qu'il raconte des histoires et des blagues à vos dépens.
Quand vous essayez d'expliquer que cela vous a blessée,
il vous arrête et vous accuse de réagir de façon excessive.
« Pourquoi es-tu si sensible ? C'est ton problème. Lâche-moi un peu. »
Ces mots vous réduisent au silence.
Cela semble évident, mais votre partenaire devrait vous soutenir.
Ses mots devraient vous élever, pas vous briser.
Il devrait garder vos secrets et être loyal.
Il devrait vous donner plus confiance en vous,
pas moins.
Pour finir, un cinquième indicateur : la volatilité.
(Vidéo) Orange 1 : Je serais triste qu'on rompe.
Orange 2 : Moi aussi. (#cestcalamour)
Orange 1 : Je serais si déprimée si on rompait.
Je sauterais de cette marche.
Je le ferais ! N'essaye pas de m'en empêcher !
(#cestpascalamour)
KH : Des ruptures et réconciliations fréquentes avec des hauts et des bas :
quand la tension monte, la volatilité s'accroît.
Des disputes pleines de larmes, de frustration
et des réconciliations intenses,
des mots dédaigneux et blessants :
« Tu ne vaux rien, je ne sais pas pourquoi je suis avec toi ! »
rapidement suivis d'excuses
et de promesses que cela ne se reproduira pas.
Arrivé là, vous avez été si habitué à ces montagnes russes amoureuses
que vous ne réalisez peut-être pas
à quel point votre relation est devenue malsaine, voire même dangereuse.
Ce peut être difficile à voir
quand un amour malsain devient de la maltraitance,
mais on peut dire que plus ces indicateurs
sont présents dans votre relation,
plus votre relation pourrait être malsaine, voire dangereuse.
Si votre instinct est de rompre et de partir,
le conseil que beaucoup donnent à leurs amis
qui sont dans une relation malsaine,
ce n'est pas toujours le meilleur conseil.
Le moment de la rupture peut susciter de la violence.
Si vous craignez être en chemin vers la maltraitance ou y être déjà,
vous devez consulter des experts pour obtenir des conseils
sur comment partir sans risque.
Il ne s'agit pas seulement des relations amoureuses
ni de violence.
Comprendre les indicateurs d'un amour malsain
peut vous aider à évaluer et comprendre presque toutes les relations de votre vie.
Pour la première fois, vous pourriez comprendre
pourquoi une amitié vous a déçu
ou pourquoi les interactions avec un membre de votre famille
vous laissent découragé et anxieux.
Vous pourriez voir comment votre intensité et votre jalousie
causent des problèmes avec des collègues au travail.
La compréhension est la première étape de l'amélioration
et, si vous ne pouvez pas rendre saines toutes vos relations malsaines --
vous devrez en délaisser certaines --
vous pouvez contribuer chaque jour à créer de meilleures relations.
Voici une nouvelle enthousiasmante :
cela n'est pas sorcier.
Une communication ouverte, du respect mutuel,
de la gentillesse, de la patience --
nous pouvons pratiquer ces choses au quotidien.
Et si pratiquer vous rendra certainement meilleur à cela,
je dois vous promettre que vous n'acquerrez jamais une maîtrise.
C'est mon travail,
chaque jour je pense et je parle de relations saines
et je fais quand même des choses malsaines.
L'autre jour, alors que j'essayais d'amener mes quatre enfants au bus
entre querelles, chamailleries et plaintes au sujet du petit-déjeuner,
je me suis emportée.
Avec un ton volontairement énervé,
j'ai dit :
« Taisez-vous et faites ce que je dis !
Vous êtes les pires !
Je vais vous priver d'écrans et de dessert
et de tout ce que vous pourriez apprécier dans votre vie ! »
(Rires)
D'autres en ont déjà fait de même ?
(Applaudissements)
La volatilité, le dénigrement.
Mon fils aîné s'est retourné, m'a regardée et a dit :
« Maman, ce n'est pas ça l'amour. »
(Rires)
Un instant, j'ai vraiment voulu le tuer d'avoir pointé cela.
Croyez-moi.
Puis je me suis reprise
et j'ai pensé : « Je suis fière. »
Je suis fière qu'il ait le langage pour me faire marquer une pause.
Je veux que tous mes enfants comprennent
comment on devrait les traiter
et qu'ils aient le langage et une voix à utiliser quand cela n'est pas satisfait
plutôt que de l'accepter.
Pendant trop longtemps, nous avons traité les relations comme un sujet léger,
mais les compétences relationnelles font partie des plus importantes
et des plus difficiles à acquérir.
Comprendre les indicateurs d'amour malsain
vous aident à éviter de tomber dans le piège menant à l'amour malsain,
mais comprendre et pratiquer l'art d'être sain
peut améliorer presque tous les aspects de votre vie.
Je suis entièrement convaincue
que si l'amour est un instinct et une émotion,
la capacité à aimer mieux est une compétence
que nous pouvons tous acquérir et améliorer avec le temps.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)